[Music]
you
hi I'm will Torres assistant director
with Stanford GSB SMB admissions office
today we're joined by three students
Sarah jack and rusev oh cool share their
experience with a financial aid process
Sarah Jack first of all can you start
off by telling us a little bit about
yourselves let's start with where you're
from and what you were doing before you
came to the GSB from Los Angeles and
running a charter school a kindergarten
through eighth grade and a team of
people who helped empower parents of
charter school kids from disadvantaged
communities in LA uh yep so I'm Jack I
was in London before coming to the GSB I
worked in turn around restructuring as a
consultant there and moved to the US for
the first time for Business School I'm
Marissa Bell I was in San Francisco
right before the GSB grew up in Southern
California before business school I was
working in tech on e-commerce and
product management alright so let's talk
about your journeys to the GSB many
prospects wonder if the opportunity cost
of taking time out from work to pursue
business degree is worth the return on
investment how did you come to the
decision that it was the right time for
you and and thought it was worth it so I
can I can go first I think for me when I
was considering the opportunity cost I
think I had a really interesting
conversation with a colleague of mine
who basically talked through you know it
being a marathon not a sprint and I
thought like I was trying to sprint
through work so I think they're taking
the tears out to stop and reflect was
the first thing that I really wanted to
do and then I start to look into it and
did a lot of research online and found a
lot of useful articles that talked about
the kind of payoff periods and it kind
of transformed a transformative
experience it is so for me I was
thinking about is the experience going
to be worth it and then also kind of
running the numbers Jack I spoke to
quite a few different alumni especially
a handful from the GSB to talk about
what their experiences were paying off
their loans because I really just wanted
to understand what that process looked
like having never taken out loans before
and so they helps me actually
up with a model to look at different
payoff periods given conservative or
different salary ranges and for me it
seemed very worth it and feasible and I
also think less so on the hard financial
side but more about looking at these two
years is a very efficient way to
understand what interests me and what I
wanted to pursue and that I just deemed
very invaluable because I feel often
times when you're good at something
outside of business school or in your
professional life and you will keep
doing that because you're good at it but
that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's what you want to be pursuing for
the rest of your life so I took both of
those into account and my decision to to
see that the investment was worth it
before I started my research I assumed
it was just too late for me to go to
business school I was nearing the end of
my 30s and relatively happy in my career
it had always been a dream and a couple
of conversations with alumni and my
executive coach led me to realize that
this one year in the MSX program would
give me a chance to step back and
reflect as well and to consider what
next leap I wanted to make in my career
that time and the time to really kind of
hone in on what it is I'm good at was
something that I just didn't have room
for in my my current role and this year
is given it was also a perfect time and
I've listed in my personal life that I
figured if I didn't go now I probably
wouldn't have the opportunity to go in
the future and it was a great time to do
that did you have any big financial
concerns coming into the process of
applying for a business school on how
did you address some of those concerns
yes I'm all start that I was I was
certain I couldn't afford to go to
business school coming from a background
in non-profit and looking at the view of
the former students who have gone here
the alumni and also who pursued their
MBAs elsewhere I I didn't I could just
couldn't see how the math would work out
until I learned about the loan
forgiveness program at Stanford
and was blown away blown away by the
flexibility and ability for me to take
advantage of that worry to continue to
pursue a career in a non-profit I once I
learned more about that and was able to
connect with some folks from the
admissions office and some alumni who'd
taken advantage of the program or at
least had it as a sort of that insurance
policy I had the assurance or I had the
confidence that I could come here and
and their ROI would be there for me yeah
Sarah of yet a little bit more on the
loan forgiveness program can you tell us
a little bit about that and what gave
you the confidence that this was
something that could help support your
career aspirations well when you're
looking at programs
aside from Stanford this program just
this this doesn't exist and that was
something I hadn't really realized that
at Stanford outside of Stanford I could
take advantage of the federal loan
forgiveness program which is super
restrictive it requires ten full years
it has all these like kind of catched
caches to it a technical catches and few
people are actually able to take
advantage of that that program so when I
learn more about that program I've come
I like I was so sad as I figured oh gosh
I really can't afford business school
and then when I learned about Stanford's
on their own loan forgiveness program I
realized okay this makes sense for every
six months I believe it's six months
increments or year increments whether
you're working as long as you are
working in a non-profit position
part-time or full-time that portion of
your of your salary and there's a
sliding scale as to what your salary can
be up to a certain point percentage of
that will be of your loans your tuition
your living expenses all the loans
you've taken out will be forgiven and
that that to me was just such a an
incredible benefit to offsetting the
cost that it would it would take for
someone from nonprofit background here
at Stanford great and then were there
any other concerns that y'all had as you
were thinking about Business School
I think for me working in tech you if
you invest enough time at a certain
company there's like a formula for
salary bumps and raises so my concern
was are the two years outside of like
the professional space like can i recoup
that after graduating Business School
and so I just took a hard look at like
the past figures numbers of like the
salaries that people earn right after
business school especially Stanford GSB
and kind of weighed that out with what I
would be earning had I stayed in my role
for these two years and just saw that I
would still be better off so that helped
me a lot with my decision as well some
other financial considerations I have
been helping to support my family also
leading up to this point so that was
something that I was very nervous about
as well just like how would I be able to
do that during business school um but
with the financial aid that Stanford
gave me that relieved a bunch of the
pressure so both of those kind of just
made it seem much more feasible for me
to still borrow the money and then have
enough money to be able to support my
family while in school
yeah I definitely had a lot of concerns
coming in it was kind of my biggest
worry about deciding to come into an MBA
I was convinced that the experience
would be great but I could afford it or
not was the challenge I think I spent a
lot of time speaking to the financial
aid office who were fantastic and gave
me loads of support pointed me in all
the right directions in terms of
thinking about where to get loans as an
international student what kind of
conversations to be having and then even
just down to how much your kind of daily
costs are likely to be I think as well
just the ease of access to loans gave me
confidence that they had confidence that
I'd be able to pay them back so if it
wasn't likely that I'd be able to afford
it they wouldn't be lending me the money
as easily as they could which I don't
know if that makes sense but it did to
me at the time and then just
the kind of generous financial aid
packages I think there's a really
rigorous process that they go through to
really understand each individual person
and their financial situation and I
think that gave me confidence and that
they that the GS we were really thinking
about how how to make it affordable did
any of you receive financial aid or
scholarships at other schools and what
made you choose to come to the GSB so I
actually did receive a full ride at
another Business School and through
their scholarship program ultimately I
decided to come to the GSB because the
financial aid was still very generous
but then also in working with a
financial aid office they brought to
light some of these extra scholarship
opportunities that would be made
available to me to apply to much like
Sarah covered and at the on a day what I
want to pursue after Business School I
felt like Stanford GSB could set me up
and the best way possible so I wasn't
trying to optimize for a completely free
experience but I was trying to optimize
for something that would have the best
financial but also personal ROI for
myself so I had some financial aid from
another school that I applied to and I
think the deciding factor for me was
both the generous amount that Stanford
financial aid package included and also
in the grand scheme of things I wanted
the kind of best experience and the most
transformative experience and for me
that was always the GSB so even if the
numbers are slightly different I think
it was more about if I'm gonna make the
investment it's making the right
investment as you think about your
everyday experience here are there ways
that you're able to be thoughtful about
either finances or spending that still
allow you to maximize that your time
here yeah I would say that it's
definitely a conversation that people
are having more on campus now to create
a much more inclusive environment
especially when it comes to clubs club
dues and those kinds of experiences you
can raise the concern and
I've heard that but financial aid office
and the Student Activities Office have
been super helpful and receptive to that
and they do think that there are so many
like extracurricular activities there's
so many options for how you want to
approach extracurricular activities so
if you want to spend a little more on
this one trip or this one event you can
but then there's so many other options
that you can also take advantage of and
still have a great time well the GSB so
I would say that there are a range of I
guess costs associated with all the
extracurriculars that you want to do so
that we can create a much more inclusive
environment here and as you're looking
back on your experience how would you
advise prospective students as they
think about financial aid and planning
for business school big thing for me is
when it comes to planning is think about
trying to give yourself a bit of a
buffer coming in if you can I think you
can take the loans and we talked about
the financial aid and how generous that
is and you know you can run the numbers
on the average salary data post GSB and
like you'll be okay but I think my
biggest challenge was like initial cash
flow which it sounds like a bit business
coolly but just the flow of some of the
funds if you can find yourself a little
bit of a buffer coming in I think that
would be my kind of advice or tips in
terms of how to think about it easing
some of the stress early on I would say
that's exactly right especially in my
case having never taken out loans before
and I tried to be a good budget or
before business school but maybe not as
reined in as I would have liked um just
looking at what your costs were like
your first quarter here and just being
realistic with yourself so not being too
limiting or restrictive but just really
understanding okay what are the costs or
how much am I going to need to be able
to support myself well in business
school this time and still give myself a
little wiggle room to enjoy my time here
as well so I think at first I was very
restrictive and that would stress me out
but then once I would look back
the models or whatever I had done before
to show that this was worth it I was
able to come up with a budget that
helped me thrive here at the GSB before
like planning for it after especially if
you're in the this alone or I'm a sex
program given that it's a full year and
we're fully engaged this year we are
here most of us are spending our summers
like transitioning into a job and don't
have a job right away and that requires
to have that buffer so absolutely I'd
also suggest that you just call the
financial aid office like talk to people
talk to alumni and people will be really
really supportive there are some also
financial planning tools that you
mentioned sort of modeling out your
salary and knowing you have that
confidence
given that the ROI you'll have based on
your experience here that that for me
was incredibly helpful any final words
of encouragement you might have for
applicants who are out there the GSB is
so worth it financial aid will work with
you they'll come up with packages like
Jacques said that they are confident
will help you succeed so I think it's
such a good time to just like take a
deep dive and enjoy your time here and
know that you'll be supported along the
way I also say it's an incredible
experience so worth it and when you get
here to pay attention to the the small
opportunities to have an additional
$20,000 scholarship there are these
Social Innovation certificates for
example you can apply for and then be
eligible for an additional grant that
would that I wasn't planning on and was
able to to to get so absolutely like to
pay attention to the emails and the
opportunities to be a part of the
financial aid opportunities that exist
here yeah I just sort of I couldn't I'll
be saying that it's been a truly
transformative experience so far and I
think there's only more to come and I'm
kind of excited for the summer to test
out so what we're doing you get back to
the real world for a bit
come back for next year so I think it's
been worth every penny all right and so
that's a great point to close on great
multiple points but time is worth it
this is an investment in an experience
and your future career you can learn
more about both the MBA and the MSX
program by visiting us on the web at GSB
dot stanford.edu thank you and have a
great day
[Music]